la mayoría vienen de la golpeada haití y
otros de cuba venezuela y nicaragua unos
10.500 migrantes se reunieron bajo el
puente internacional del río en la noche
del jueves protegiéndose de las olas de
calor que alcanzan temperaturas de
alrededor de los 37 grados celsius las
condiciones de lo que ahora es un
campamento improvisado son miserables y
los suministros de comida y agua se
están agotando la patrulla fronteriza
anunció que incrementará su personal en
del río texas en respuesta a la nueva
emergencia fronteriza que enfrenta la
administración de vall de la patrulla
fronteriza está incrementando sus tropas
en el sector del río y coordinando
esfuerzos con el departamento de
seguridad nacional y otras oficinas
federales estatales y locales para
abordar el nivel de migrantes y para
facilitar un proceso seguro humano y
ordenado
la aglomeración se da cuando el cruce
ilegal alcanza las cifras más altas en
20 años y al tiempo que el gobierno de
eeuu está batallando por el
reasentamiento de migrantes afganos se
cree que los migrantes que han llegado a
del río hacen parte de una oleada de
haitianos que va hacia eeuu muchos de
los cuales llegaron a suramérica tras el
terremoto de 2010 según las más
recientes cifras de la patrulla
fronteriza por lo menos 29 mil haitianos
han llegado a eeuu en los últimos 11
meses los más recientes tras el
asesinato del presidente haitiano yop en
el moritz y el devastador terremoto de
agosto la administración de uairén
restringió en los vuelos de deportación
hacia haití y extendió la elegibilidad
de los haitianos para el estatuto
temporal de protección
aiden ha revertido muchas de las duras
medidas de inmigración implementadas por
el expresidente donald trump lo que le
ha valido críticas tanto de grupos
humanitarios por no darle ayuda
suficiente a los migrantes como de sus
opositores de derecha que dicen que el
mandatario está incentivando la
inmigración ilegal